The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Thoughts.
Important concepts of the week?
AUDIENCE: Principal axes.
PROFESSOR: Principal axes.
Good one.
Another one.
AUDIENCE: Dynamic
versus static balances.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Another one.
AUDIENCE: Symmetry.
Symmetry.
PROFESSOR: Symmetry.
Right.
This is in the context of things
like the mass moment of inertia
matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Parallel axis theorem.
PROFESSOR: Parallel
axis theorem.
OK.
We haven't done much
with it yet but we're
going to come back to it.
All right.
Pretty good list.
We only had one lecture.
Dynamic and static balancing.
Let's talk about
that for a second.
static balancing.
Tell me what are features
of static balancing?
How can you-- you
have a quiz problem,
it's on the final-- you have an
object and an axis about which
its spinning and you're
asked, is this statically
balanced or not.
What would you look for?
Christina.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: G needs to be--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] axis.
PROFESSOR: So another way of
saying that is the axis must--
the axis of rotation
must pass through--
AUDIENCE: The center.
PROFESSOR: --G. Is that
what you're trying to say?
The center of mass?
Everybody agree about that?
All right.
Now, if I have
weird shaped object,
I know where the
center of mass, and I
stick the axis of rotation at
any angle at all through it,
is it statically
balance regardless
of where I have the
x-axis of rotation passing
through the center of mass?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: I hear a yes.
How about the other people?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
So how do you-- I think
that's probably right.
But how do you test it?
How do you test to see--
what's a simple test you
can form to see if something
is statically balanced?
AUDIENCE: See if it goes
through a low point.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you make the axis that
you're rotating about horizontal
and see if the thing
seeks a low point.
Because if it does, it's
telling you that what
about the center of mass?
AUDIENCE: It's not
going through the--
PROFESSOR: It's not
going through the axis.
To go to a low point, it
means the center of mass
is somewhere below
the axis of spin.
Right?
But any axis at all, as
long as its through G,
you are statically balanced.
Dynamic balancing.
What are the-- what would you
look for on an object to say
is this dynamically
balanced or not?
What kind of properties?
AUDIENCE: There would
be no unbalanced torques
if you decided to rotate it.
PROFESSOR: So you're looking
for now unbalanced torques.
AUDIENCE: Because I'm like if
it-- if the object is rotating
about the axis that
you have it on,
you won't need to supply an
extra torque to try and keep
it balanced.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: --pretty convincing.
AUDIENCE: --the axis
it's rotating on.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If you put in that
last caveat then
it's getting pretty correct.
Can there be a torque on
it that's not balanced
and have it be
dynamically balanced?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: Within the
axis of rotation.
PROFESSOR: If you have a torque
that's in the axis of spin
and around the axis of
rotation and that torque
will cause what to happen?
AUDIENCE: Rotation.
PROFESSOR: Cause the
rotation rate to?
AUDIENCE: Change.
PROFESSOR: Change, right?
That puts energy into the
system and accelerates it.
And it's a torque that's in the
direction of spin that doesn't
cause dynamic imbalances.
But a torque that is other
than in the direction of spin,
that's what a
dynamic imbalance is.
So what are some other ways you
can say this in terms of things
like evidence of--
let's say I give you H
and I give you omega,
how can you just
tell by looking at
those two thing?
I give you the angle of momentum
and I give you the spin,
how can you tell
instantly whether or not
it is dynamically balanced?
AUDIENCE: If there--
each of the components
in the same direction.
PROFESSOR: So you're saying
if H and omega are in the--
AUDIENCE: R line.
PROFESSOR: A line.
They just have to be parallel.
If they're aligned, you do not
have any dynamic imbalance.
That sound right?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
matter if they're
parallel or
antiparallel, does it?
PROFESSOR: You mean
just opposite senses?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I think that'd
be really hard to do.
I don't know of
any-- I don't think
you can make that system that
has angular momentum that
is negative-- it's actually
opposite the direction
of the rotation rate.
I don't think it-- I don't
think our universe supports
that physics.
But anyway, in any case,
they're aligned, you're OK.
All right?
Let's move on.
So today we're
going actually just
have you work a couple problems.
And you really are going to work
in groups, and when you finish,
one of the groups is
going to come up and fill
in the blanks of the
answer to the problem
and we'll talk about it.
And we're going to
work two problems.
And they have to do
with things that spin.
And as a quick review
just of information--
I guess we can do this.
So the problem is a simple one.
It's basically this.
And I decided to lubricate
it and it made the wood swell
and so now it won't spin at all.
Actually, unless I
let the axis spin.
So it's just this problem.
The axis passes through
the center of mass
and it looks just like this.
And I've got an x-axis aligned
with the axis of the rod.
The Z is this way.
And the spin is cap omega.
And the mass moment
of inertia matrix
for this problem
about G-- and our axis
is passing through G-- so mass
moment of inertia matrix times
omega gives you H. So here's the
mass moment of inertia matrix.
I claim is going to be diagonal.
And the test of that, can
you tell me whether or not
I've chosen axes that, just
from symmetry, you know
will be principal axes?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: Well, the rod is
circular now that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So one axis-- that's an axis
of symmetry is down the shaft.
So that's guaranteed to be one.
Have I chosen one like that?
And any other orthogonal
pair after that--
doesn't matter which way I
orient them-- will also be.
So I've got one up and
one into the board.
So those are principal
axes for this object.
So it's going to be diagonal.
And in fact, it looks--
it's MR squared over 2,
ML squared over 12,
and ML squared over 12
when you work it out.
And if you look up in the
book, most books for slen--
what they call
slender rods, will
say that this first term is 0.
And that's because
they're saying
that L is a lot bigger than
R-- the radius of this thing.
And so MR squared is
a pretty small number.
So it's energy and
rotation spinning this way
is not very big for
its angular momentum.
But its angular momentum
spinning like this
is much, much larger because you
have much greater MR squareds.
So you can leave, for the
purpose of this problem,
you can't treat this as 0.
And in your groups, I want
you to come up with the omega
vector, H and DHDT.
So do get in groups,
talk about it.
You've got a few
minutes to do this.
This one's pretty
straightforward.
And then you can do another
one that's harder so warm up
and find a group to
work in and you're
going to work a couple
of problems this way.
Got a group that feels pretty
good about they're answer?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Write it up.
Come up, fill in the
omega, H and DHDT.
OK.
Can everybody see it?
So you have a Z component only
for the omega, a Z component k
hat only for H, and its
i omega-- iZZ omega.
And DHDT, the only
variable here is omega
and you get an omega dot.
And there's no--
DKDT is 0 because it
doesn't change direction.
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I was a
little bit confused
in lecture about how we knew
the i hat, j hat, k hat in the H
term.
Is it just because
it's only i hat
on the top, j hat in the
middle, and k hat on the bottom?
Is that--
PROFESSOR: So the convention--
if I understand your question
correctly-- the convention
when you write out the H vector
is it's the result of
multiplying the three
components of the spin.
This is the piece
in the i direction,
j direction, k direction.
And you multiply these
out you get three results.
Vector times-- and this one
is Hx and it is in the i.
The second one from this times
the middle row gives you Hy
and it's in the j.
And the third one, this
vector times these three
in the bottom row,
give you Hz in the k.
AUDIENCE: So I thought
when-- I don't know,
I could be completely wrong--
but I thought when you did
[INAUDIBLE] you multiplied this,
this, this and then this, this,
this and then--
PROFESSOR: So we have a
capital A, capital B, capital C
terms in the first row?
AUDIENCE: So you
do, like, this and--
PROFESSOR: And you have
a capital-- little a,
little b, little c
terms in this one.
When you multiply
this times this,
you get Aa plus Bb plus Cc.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So that's my question.
So if you have the
omega x is an i hat,
omega y is a j hat,
omega z's a k hat,
how, if you're
multiplying like this,
do you get only i hats
on the top of the thing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Well, it's because this
isn't just a matrix.
This is actually a tensor.
And we haven't gone into
messy tensor notation.
So you're just being
told a convention here.
And that is, because this
is a vector being multiplied
by a tensor, the result will--
even though this is i, j, k,
omega xi times this first
term in this tensor,
it gives you an i back.
Omega yj times this one
gives you an i back.
Omega zk times that
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's what I was
really confused --
PROFESSOR: Right.
And that's a great question
because it wasn't obvious.
We didn't do the full
tensor mathematic.
We just gave you a
result. By definition,
this row times that is in the
i direction, j direction, k
direction.
Great question.
OK.
So let's go on to
harder problem.
So you're great at that one.
We're going to do this one now.
So we just did this problem.
Now we want to do this problem.
And so the same i
matrix is used here.
It's this one and you
can let that term is 0
because the
coordinate system that
has been defined on this object
is x, z, y into the board.
But the direction of
spin now is like that.
And we'll call it
cap omega again.
But it's in that direction.
And these are 45 degree
angles for the purposes
of this problem.
So that's sine cosine
of 45 root 2 over 2.
So now, what's omega?
What's H?
And what's DHDT?
So work in groups and
sort that one out.
You ready to go?
AUDIENCE: We can be.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Go for it.
We'll probably do
this occasionally.
I'll say it again.
I have no intention of
embarrassing you at the board.
So the practice will be, you
put your answer up, you sit down
and then we talk about it.
It's not about you.
It's about what's on the board.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Should I
keep going or should--
PROFESSOR: No.
Put the whole thing up.
Yep.
And if you want to use that big
piece of chalk it shows better.
Just to your right.
OK.
So let's talk about omega first.
How do you figure-- we have
a minus root 2 over 2 here.
Can't see that.
Minus root 2 over 2 omega
i 0 root 2 over 2 omega k.
Are people-- feel
good about that?
Any differences?
All right.
So this thing-- this
omega-- that spin clearly
has components that are
like that and like this.
So this is your z
piece and your i piece.
And it is, indeed, in the
minus i hat direction.
So that seems OK.
And H would be some
i-- the i times omega.
And the first term, if you
take that upper left term as 0,
then you don't get anything.
The second term you
don't get anything.
So how do you feel about
the angular momentum?
Any differences?
OK.
And the DHDT.
You take the time
derivative of this thing--
and you got an omega dot.
OK.
That looks OK as far as it goes.
But any other thoughts?
AUDIENCE: So k hat dot is not 0.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you're saying k hat
is changing with time.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And let's
think about that.
So it's-- that's
this piece here.
This is omega z k hat.
And as this thing goes around
that unit vector is doing this.
Right?
So you need a DkDT.
So do you want to give--
somebody else give me
the second term here?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
ML squared times omega
squared because you
have the changing directions
in your k hat principal axes.
And that's going to
be-- well, times root 2.
PROFESSOR: This is root--
AUDIENCE: Well, omega squared.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then what about
the root 2 over 2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Got to
square that too, right?
AUDIENCE: That'd
be squared as well.
PROFESSOR: That
gives you a half.
OK.
And--
AUDIENCE: That's
over 12 as well.
PROFESSOR: 12.
And--
AUDIENCE: That would be
in the j hat direction.
PROFESSOR: Positive--
AUDIENCE: Positive.
Yes.
In this case.
PROFESSOR: Started out
with a negative but--
AUDIENCE: Negative [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: i cross k is minus
j times a minus gives you
the plus, right?
So this looks-- this
comes out ML squared omega
squared j hat over 24 I think.
Like that.
That term.
Now-- OK.
And people good with that now?
So just to remind you, when
I was doing these problems--
when I first had to teach
this course a few years ago,
and I was trying to figure
out an easy way to teach this
and how to do these problems,
I got myself all confused
trying to figure out which
components of the rotation
vector are rotating and what
do I have to cross into it
to get the answer.
And in fact, you
don't have to make it
anywhere near that hard.
And let's take a quick
look at something here.
H is ML squared over
12 root 2 over 2--
where did H go-- root
2 over 2 omega k hat.
H is a rotating vector.
A derivative of a rotating
vector in an inertial frame
is the derivative of that
rotating vector in the rotating
frame.
Which is the same
thing as saying
that omega is 0-- that's
the change in length
of the vector--
plus omega cross H.
Let's test that and see if
that gives us the right answer.
This derivative gives you-- all
it does is gives you the theta,
the omega dot back.
Right?
That's that first term.
And the second term
should just then
look like your omega, which
is root 2 minus root 2
over 2 cap omega i plus
root 2 over 2 cap omega k
cross a bunch of
constants times k.
Right?
So the k cross k terms are?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: 0.
The i cross k--
AUDIENCE: Minus j.
PROFESSOR: --minus j.
And so you get root 2 over
2 times root 2 over 2.
You get what's in
H here multiplied
by root 2 over 2 omega hat.
And you get back
exactly these two terms.
So it's that easy.
It's just the derivative
of a rotating vector.
Just doing omega
cross H is the easiest
way to deal with that derivative
of the rotating piece.
Any rotating
vector, you can take
this time derivative that way.
All right.
We've got a few minutes.
I want to-- actually,
any other questions
about this kind of problem?
In physics, most of the
problems you've worked before,
that involved rotation,
are planar-- what
we call planar motion problems.
The axis of spin was always
perpendicular to the plane
and the rest the problem
was confined to the plane.
So hockey pucks sliding
along and stuff like that.
But it was always assumed
that the axis of rotation
was perpendicular to the
plane and that the angular
momentum was parallel.
So this is actually--
this is 3D problem.
This is a 3D dynamics problem.
As soon as that H and the
omega are different directions,
you can come up with torques
in all three directions.
Right?
All right.
So any other
questions about this?
And if not, I want to talk about
something that was on the quiz.
OK.
So here's-- this is the one
problem on the quiz that gave
more conceptual difficulty
than any other single problem.
People made mistakes
on other problems,
but got into conceptual
trouble with this problem.
Remember, you had a
vehicle driving up a bridge
and the bridge could be
changing at some angular rate
and it has some
angular acceleration.
And we said to keep
the problem simple,
that you could treat
this as a particle.
And that really
means you didn't have
to deal with angular momentum.
i omega for the object.
You could just treat
it like a particle.
And one of the-- where
the confusion came from
was in figuring out
free body diagrams.
You're told in the problem
the language is something
like, the action of the tires on
the road result in a net force
up the incline called t.
We didn't call it friction,
we didn't say anything,
but people-- a number of people
got confused about what's
that have to do with friction.
How does friction
come into this?
So let's do the free body
diagram for this thing.
So tell me what's--
here's my car,
tell me what to put on
the free body diagram.
AUDIENCE: Weight.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Mg?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So you've got an Mg.
Next.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A normal force?
OK.
That's going this
way we'll call it.
AUDIENCE: T.
PROFESSOR: T. OK.
Now, what about the
tires on the road?
What about friction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: That is T.
PROFESSOR: That is T. So you
think of the free body diagram,
you just say, what are
all the possible sources
of external force on this thing?
And they come from gravity--
a body force-- and then
other things that are
in contact with it.
And the wheels are in
contact with the road.
And through the wheels
you get the normal force.
And through the wheels you
get any active friction.
So that is the-- that's
total net friction force.
And then once you
got that far, you
were asked to come up
with an equation of motion
in this direction.
In the direction up the bridge.
And how do you-- so when you go
to get an equation of motion,
you say, the sum of the
external forces is equal to?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: And we'll make
these in the x direction here.
Is the mass times
the acceleration
in the x direction.
And how would--
what terms appear?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: T.
PROFESSOR: Well,
those are the forces.
They're on the other side.
I want you to come up
with the accelerations.
You need to come up with
the acceleration terms.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: So this problem
most easily to think through,
I think, in terms of
r and theta and polar
coordinates because you've
worked dozens of times
with a complete acceleration of
something in a rotating system.
And this is a rotating system.
Polar coordinates is a pretty
good way to do this problem.
So what are the accelerations
in this direction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
r and theta?
PROFESSOR: Well, I do
it in terms of-- well,
I do it in terms of r and theta.
Given a theta dot and a
theta double dot and x and r
mount up to the same thing.
But I-- if you call it r,
you'll recognize the terms
in your acceleration equation.
So what are the accelerations
in the direction up to bridge?
AUDIENCE: r double dot?
AUDIENCE: r double dot.
AUDIENCE: Minus r theta dot.
PROFESSOR: And those
are all in the-- you
get all of that in
the i direction.
And then if you looked
at that, obviously,
you could replace r double
dot with x double dot.
r with x if you make
your origin here.
Which you probably would.
That's the point of rotation.
So that is your-- that's the
mass times the acceleration
in the direction of travel.
And it's got to be
equal to T and minus
Mg sine theta probably.
Right?
And that's one
equation of motion.
And you're going to do
another equation of motion
in the theta dot--
theta hat direction.
Because what other--
what accelerations
are present in this direction?
In the y j hat?
AUDIENCE: Theta double dot?
PROFESSOR: Theta double dot.
You're [INAUDIBLE] one.
What else?
So the sum of the
forces in the y--
so they are, in terms of
polar coordinate terms?
AUDIENCE: 2 omega-- 2 omega dot.
PROFESSOR: Somebody
said this one first.
Plus 2 theta dot is your--
AUDIENCE: It's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
2 theta dot--
AUDIENCE: r dot.
PROFESSOR: r dot.
And that's in the j direction.
And now you've got-- now
you can work the problem.
So how would you go about
doing this problem where
you can't treat it as
a particle any longer?
We've graduated to
that because we've
been doing-- we've been
doing angular momentum
stuff with mass moment
of inertia matrices.
So now you want to do this
more as a full fledged dynamics
problem, taking into
consideration that.
So how do you-- what
is the mass-- what
do you have to modify-- do to
modify our free body diagram?
Here's my simplified vehicle.
What are the forces on it
that you need to deal with?
AUDIENCE: Well, there
are two normal forces.
There are two normal forces.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So you can add-- need
two because you've
got two wheels on this thing.
And so there's axle one here- so
you get one here and one here.
I call this one N1, N2.
What else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The same T and Mg.
PROFESSOR: So you've
got a g somewhere.
And so you still
have an Mg term.
What other external forces?
AUDIENCE: T?
PROFESSOR: T. But
now T's the problem.
So as I gave you before,
T is the total net force.
But that's not adequate in
this problem any longer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So we're going to end up
having a friction force that's
supplied here-- f1-- and
another one applied here-- f2.
And f1 plus f2 would be T. OK.
So how many unknowns do we have?
AUDIENCE: Four?
PROFESSOR: Well, it
looks like four are here.
Plus any motion stuff that
you have to solve for.
So how many equations
of motion can you write?
Remember, you get one equation
for every vector component
direction.
So x, y, z gives
you three components
and you could conceivably
write three equations.
So tell me the relevant
equations of motion
that we could come up
with for this problem.
AUDIENCE: Sum forces
in x, sum forces in y.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I argue-- sum of
the forces in x.
That's still true.
Yep.
Sum of the forces in y you said.
Is this 0?
No.
Because that bridge is moving.
OK.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Torque.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And how do you do that?
Sum of the torques
in what direction?
AUDIENCE: Theta hat.
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
Yeah.
Well, you could.
Excuse me.
I shouldn't say that.
Do you have more
than one torque term
that you can work with here?
More than one torque equation?
AUDIENCE: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: How's that?
So let's just think
through these things.
You could have a torque--
you could have a torque in,
this is x, y, z
out of the board.
You could have a z torque
making this thing trying
to pitch up and down.
You could have an x torque
making it trying to rollover.
But we don't have any
information in that direction
and its constrained.
And we could have a y torque
making it try to go like that.
And we don't have much
information there.
So it seems like
we've got a z torque
equation that we could write.
And that's one-- seems like
we got three equations.
Sum of the forces x,
sum of the forces y,
and a torque in the z.
And doesn't seem
like quite enough.
And that's as far as
I've gotten with it.
I just thought of this
on the way over here.
So I'd sit down and start
working this out and trying
to figure out, where is
my fourth equation going
to come from?
And I'm not exactly
sure quite yet.
But, generally, I'd go about
setting it up like that
and start working
those things out.
OK.
Any other questions or
questions about the quiz?
We're done early.